this video is made possible by brilliant
you're gonna learn more about brilliant
later in today's video but if you'd like
to learn more about them right now got a
brilliant a talk /pi graphics you'll
also find a link in the description
below Leon Trotsky was a man of thought
and action his dream of a utopian
society built on Marxism it crumbled
around him yet he never gave up on his
ideals when he was sidelined by the
power-hungry Josef Stalin he wielded his
pen to expose the despot to the world
knowing full well that in doing so he
was signing his own death warrant in
today's by graphics we discover the man
who was Leon Trotsky
[Music]
the man who is known to history as Leon
Trotsky was born Lev Davidovich
Bronstein on November the 7th 1879 his
parents David and Anna were farmers in
the Ukrainian village of Yankovic
David had built himself up from nothing
to become one of the most successful
farmers in the entire region Lev was the
fifth child born to the Bronstein's
during his first eight years he was kept
on the farm and instructed by his
parents the language they spoke was a
mixture of Russian and Ukrainian then at
the age of eight he was sent to a
private Ukrainian Jewish school in
Odessa in Ukraine Lev struggled during
his first year at school as he was not
familiar with the vernacular of Jewish
Yiddish that was spoken in time though
he improved and he proved himself to be
a very capable students he quickly
learned to speak Russian and he fell in
love with Russian literature after two
years at the private school Lev was
transferred to a state-run Russian
school as in Paul's high school he
excelled to be one of the top students
however he proved to be an independent
thinker which sometimes led to run-ins
with his teachers his reading of such
intellectual giants like Leo Tolstoy
gave him the knowledge to challenge
things that the other students accepted
about the order of society which caused
frustration for his long-suffering
instructors graduating from school at
the age of 17 Lev moved to the Ukrainian
port town of Nikolaev close to the Black
Sea
he lived with two relatives swarley
decided what he wanted to do with his
life nikolai of at that time was a
center of revolutionary descent and the
teenage life soon began to mingle with
the radical crowd
within a few months of arriving in
nikolayeva lev met a young woman by the
name of alexandra sokolovskaya she was
six years older than Levin's well versed
in revolutionary leftist politics Lev
later recalled that he was attracted to
Alexandra because she was the only
person who was able to defeat him in a
debate the subject at issue was Marxism
and whether it would be the best thing
for Russian society Lev argued against
it was every arguments that he made was
deftly destroyed by the wit and the
wisdom of Alexandra love he found
himself falling in love with her but
hardly before the relationship could get
established he was thrown in jail the
cause of his imprisonment in January of
1898 was his involvement in a
demonstration of striking union members
over the next two years he was
irregularly thrown in jail for short
spells as a result of his involvement in
public demonstrations in 1911 Alexandra
they were married shortly after the
wedding Alexandra was banished to
Siberia for four years as a result of
her own radical activities a new husband
though he went right along with that
they ended up in the Siberian village of
oast caught over the next two years they
eat out a living in this cold and harsh
terrain the couple also had two children
girls named Sanada and Nina after two
years of this exile Lev had already had
enough he was ready to make his escape
by now his wife had fully converted him
to Marxism communism and he was
determined to get out of this purgatory
and become active in the revolutionary
cause it was a resolve that Alexandra
would remain in Siberia with the two
young children
let travel to the Irkutsk region of
Siberia there it got ahold of a stolen
Passport
it was then that he assumed his new name
scribbling it's on the pages of the fake
passport Leon Trotsky he made his way to
London eager to learn at the feet of the
founder of Russian Marxism Vladimir
Lenin the two men developed an immediate
bonds Lenin took Trotsky on as his
apprentice setting him to work as a
writer for his communist newspaper Iskra
within a couple of months of his arrival
Lenin sent him out on a fundraising and
publicity tour of Europe to promote the
newspaper as well as the Communist cause
on the Paris leg of the tour he met a
young woman by the name of Natalya
Sedova despite still being married to
Alexandra he and Natalya soon became man
and wife she returned with him to London
and they set up house there no long
after his return from Europe Trotsky
attended the second Congress of the
Democratic Workers Party in London the
main topic of discussion was the recent
split in the Russian Communist Party
between the Mensheviks and the
Bolsheviks the Mensheviks were the more
moderate of the two factions who
envisions a gradual transition to
communism
the Bolsheviks however they were far
more radical they intended to dismantle
the current system immediately and
replace it with full-on communism they
were fully prepared to stage violent
uprising in order to achieve their means
the names of these factions they tell us
about their levels of support the
Menshevik means men of the minority
while Bolsheviks translates to men of
the majority nothing was in favor of the
Bolsheviks at the Congress meeting he
explained the Bolsheviks needed to
create a centralized power structure
from which they could control and direct
the common people this idea it was very
troubling to Trotsky who saw it as a
replacement of the type of capitalist
control of the masses that they were
trying to get rid of for many years
after that he continued to try and
bridge the divide between the Bolsheviks
and the Mensheviks
[Music]
in 1905 Russia suffered a humiliating
defeat against the Japanese in the
Battle of Tsushima they'd left the
Russian economy in ruins and led to mass
demonstrations on January the 22nd 1905
the peaceful demonstration gathered
outside of Tsar Nicholas Winter Palace
Nicholas reacted by sending in the
cavalry the demonstrators were routed
with hundreds being killed in the street
the people they were outraged in the
Bolshevik ranks however celebrations
began to occur they saw this as the
spark that would bring on the great
Communist revolution over the following
months protests grew larger morphing
into the general strike of October 1905
over that period of time the Bolsheviks
they were busy organizing the resistance
both Lenin and Trotsky had relocated to
San Petersburg Trotsky began organizing
special workers assemblies these groups
were designed to take control of regions
that were to be governed by a workers
council the Russian word for council
will out be Soviet Trotsky set up the
first Soviet in San Petersburg with him
serving as its chairman in short order
the region was surrounded by the Tsarist
army and Trotsky was taken into
captivity he was held in prison for
nearly a year before being put on trial
defending the charge of leading the
armed rebellion Trotsky gave an
impressive speech in which he laid out
all the benefits of Marxism all of this
was in vain however as he was convicted
and he was exiled once again to Siberia
[Music]
Trotsky determined that there was no way
that he was going back to that Siberian
wilderness in January of 1907 he escaped
while being transported to his place of
banishment for a second time he headed
off to London within weeks though he had
relocated to Vienna in Austria it was
there that he started working for the
communist propaganda newspaper Pravda
financing the ongoing publication of
Pravda was a constant challenge in 1909
Trotsky requested that the Bolshevik
Central Committee inject funds to keep
the paper going Lenin now at the head of
the Bolsheviks agreed but only on the
condition that a Bolshevik be put in
place as assistant editor this means
that the moderate views which Trotsky
had managed to infuse into the paper
were no longer going to be acceptable
from 1910 onwards Pravda became the
mouthpiece of Bolshevik communism
tensions between the Bolsheviks and the
Mensheviks they continued to cause
division in 1912 Lenin instigated a
purge to remove the moderate voices
Trotsky remains in opposition to the
more radical actions of the Bolsheviks
such as armed robberies of banks to
finance the party he organized a
unification conference to bring the
factions together but it was a failure
[Music]
throughout 1912 Trotsky wrote for a
number of radical Russian and Ukrainian
newspapers in September of that year he
was sent on assignment to cover the
balkan war when World War one broke outs
he moved from Austria to Switzerland and
then to Paris from his base there he
wrote anti-war diatribes in which he
describes the injustice of the workers
of the world who were being forced to
kill each other at the beckoning of
their rulers the French governments they
were not impressed with this anti-war
stance and their Trotsky deported on
March 31st 1916 Trotsky he went to Spain
birds his writings led to deportation
from that country as well he ultimately
ended up in the United States he arrived
in New York on January the 13th 1917 he
settled into a small room in the Bronx
and began writing for several Russian
newspapers a month after his arrival in
the US Trotsky received the news that
Tsar Nicholas had been overthrown he
decided to return in order to play his
part in the history that was unfolding
on March the 27th 1917 Trotsky sailed
from New York Harbor on board the SS
Christiana fort however the ship was
intercepted by the British Navy at
Halifax Nova Scotia and Trotsky was held
in an internment camp for a month
through the intervention of the Russian
Foreign Minister he was released and he
was able to continue on to Russia now
just before we get into the very
important October Revolution I do want
to tell you a bit about brilliant
brilliant art a science learning
platform that allow you to learn through
active learning basically summed up this
is the opposite of that feeling where
you read a really complex paragraph
about some principle and then you've
just got no clue what on earth is going
on even if you've read it through ten
times you're still like huh anyway and
brilliant don't just teach you the
basics although they do cover that as
well they go all the way to complex
things like differential equations now
you've heard me talk a bunch about
brilliant previously if you're a regular
viewer and I think that a perfect fit
for this channel because hey you're
probably into learning and education
because you're on YouTube and you're
watching as a 20-minute educational
video so you're into learning you're
into this channel you probably be into
brilliant too recently brilliant made an
important update to their mobile app so
that now courses can be accessed offline
so you don't have to worry about having
a solid internet connection to learn
things through their platform maybe this
means you can spend your commute
learning some
or did you can learn something wherever
you want brilliant makes even complex
concepts easy to understand they give
you something super short to read it's
really easy and then you immediately
apply it to a problem for intz and
repeats and suddenly you're
understanding all sorts of stuff that
you didn't think you'd ever get all of
course is a totally interactive so you
can learn probability by playing
blackjack or you can learn the physics
of motion using interactive models of
pendulum clocks so if you want to
support via graphics which would be
awesome and get unlimited access to all
of brilliance in-depth math and science
courses you can head over to brilliant
org forward slash bhaiyya graphics and
get 20% off their annual premium
subscription and let's get back to
Trotsky and his revolution
[Music]
following the ousting of Tsar Nicholas
the supposedly neutral provisional
government was put into place until a
more permanent government could be
established
Trotsky arrived in San Petersburg on May
the 17th 1917 he soon became the popular
speaker at town halls and factories as
the various political elements vying for
power his catchphrase embodied the three
tenets of his revolutionary vision
distrust the bourgeoisie control our own
leaders and have confidence in our
revolutionary forces the Bolsheviks they
struggled for more radical changes than
the state government or Duma envisions
Trotsky aligned himself with the
Bolsheviks he was arrested on August the
7th for his involvement in a Bolshevik
demonstration they spent 40 days in
prison it's probably used to that at
this point on October the 8th with the
Bolshevik support gaining ascendancy
Trotsky was voted governor of the San
Petersburg Soviet for a second time by
the end of the year the provisional
government's it had failed it was
superseded by the Bolsheviks with Lenin
at the head the second most powerful man
was Leon Trotsky
[Music]
an immediate focus for the Bolshevik
government was to get Russia out of the
war this task was handed to Trotsky
along with the title of people's
commissar for Foreign Affairs on
December the 2nd 1917 the Bolsheviks
signed ceasefire with the allied Central
Powers of Germany austria-hungary and
turkey talks then began between Trotsky
and the central power delegates to work
out an armistice agreement the Germans
in particular they drove a hard bargain
they demanded that the Russians give up
their claim to Ukraine Poland Lithuania
as well as parts of Latvia and Bella
Russia Trotsky was taken aback by the
demands but he also knew that he had
little choice
the Bolsheviks had campaigns on a
platform of getting Russia out of the
war and all of Russia was essentially
demanding that Trotsky he related the
demands to Lenin adding that he felt
they had no choice but to agree then and
he was of the same opinion but when the
rest of the Bolshevik government heard
the demands they were infuriated they
managed to convince both Trotsky and
Lenin not to sign the armistice in the
end Trotsky simply decided to pull out
of the hostilities without the benefit
of an armistice agreements he explains
we declare we end the war but will not
sign a peace they will be unable to make
an offensive against us if they attack
us our position will be no worse than
now it was a gamble that Trotsky would
immediately regret On February the 18th
1918 Austrian and German forces they
invaded Russia they found the borders
completely undefended on hearing the
news
Trotsky he was dumbfounded he sent a
message to the German ambassador stating
we request clarification of this
misunderstanding
but there was no misunderstanding the
very next day Trotsky was commanded by
Lenin to accept the original German
conditions for the armistice
with Russia now out of the war Trotsky
was made commander-in-chief of the
Russian armed forces a crisis occurred
when the Czechoslovak legions returning
from the war revolted against the
Bolshevik governments the resistance
grew and what became known as the white
army when he heard that the outpost of
Kazan had fallen to this opposition
Trotsky hopped on a train and headed for
the area to assess the situation for
himself his train only made it part of
the way before he was forced and turned
back but before they could get out of
town the White Army forces that
surrounded trotsky's contingent for 25
days they were forced to fend off the
assault until they were finally able to
break out and returned to San Petersburg
with the white army challenging them
from the East the Baltics also faced
pressure from the north as a finish
group known as the white guard sought to
rescued Tsar Nicholas and his family
from captivity the group were on the
verge of taking control of the town of
yet Ehrenberg which is where the royal
family were being held captive then the
order came through to kill the entire
royal family with this terrible deed
done the Bolsheviks were ousted from the
town however the white guards they were
simply too late to save Nicholas or his
family at the beginning of 1919 Russia
it was in a state of crisis civil wars
had wracked the country hands now
disease famine and poverty decimated the
population meanwhile European powers
hovered around like vultures ready to
devour the Russian corpse by October the
White Army had almost total control and
were pressing at the gates of some
Petersburg the Soviet government ordered
a full-scale retreat from the capital
but Trotsky he strongly disagreed he
rallied his supporters to resist to the
very last man trotsky's bravery
persistence and strong personality turns
the tide the Soviet forces dug in and
managed to push back the white army some
Petersburg was safe and the tide of the
Civil War it began to change in favor of
the Bolsheviks by the end of 1920 the
White Army had been concentrated in
Siberia the Soviets had survived to see
off their enemies and cement their
leadership however in May of 1922 their
leader and visionary Vladimir Lenin in a
massive stroke
Trotsky would have seemed to have been
the natural successor however there was
another member of the Bolshevik power
structure who had other ideas and his
name of course was Joseph Stalin
Joseph Stalin was a street fighter and a
thug who would cajole his way into
becoming the general secretary of the
Soviet Union by the time that Lenin died
the position it didn't hold any real
power with all of his actions being
controlled by the executive committee or
the police of Euro by the end of 1922
Lenin had recovered sufficiently to send
a note to the politico
giving his thoughts on his successor he
stated that Trotsky was a stronger
personality than Stalin but that he was
too prone to acting unilaterally without
consulting the rest of the council as
for Stalin he considered him to be too
rude too ruthless and too intolerant
Lenin held on until January the 21st
1924 during that time it became clear to
Stalin that the dying leader favoured
Trotsky over him this led him to embark
on a ruthless campaign to discredit
Trotsky he claimed that Trotsky was
trying to cause divisions within the
party by trying to push out the old
guards in favor of younger members who
were more inclined to his will
Stalin managed have a book that Trotsky
had written in 1923 banned from sale as
being anti Leninist even though it was
nothing of the sort the open and
constant criticisms of Trotsky resulted
in the loss of his two offices as
chairman of the war council and people's
commissar of war and Navy after spending
almost all of 1925 without a job Trotsky
was recalled in 1926 and given three
roles however Stalin interfered so much
that he resigned from two of them only
retaining the position of chairman of
the concessions committee
but Stalin was not through with Trotsky
yet on November the 12th 1927 he had him
expelled from the Communist Party and
then axon to Kazakhstan three months
later he was completely banned from
living in the Soviet Union Soviet guards
they forced him onto a train and would
not tell him where he was going after
going on a hunger strike he was finally
informed that he was headed for Turkey
this enraged Trotsky who was convinced
that the anti-communist regime there
would haven't executed immediately he
sends a message to the Central Committee
requesting a change of heart but there
was no response surprisingly though the
Turks they treated Trotsky with the
greatest respect he was given a home to
live in with his wife and his Harley
Ahrens their son Lev from his new base
he began writing about the situation
within the Soviet Union and specifically
the failings of Stalin he didn't talk
back writing the following in an article
titled what is Stalin his political
horizon is extremely narrow he has the
mentality of a dogged empiricist devoid
of creative imagination these writings
were published in newspapers around the
world knowing what we do now about
Stalin's personality it is a wonder that
he didn't have Trotsky killed
immediately but to have done so would
have been to bring the condemnation of
the world down on Stalin as a result he
sought to shut him up by sending him
deeper into exile the Turks received
orders to remove Trotsky to the island
of print Copiah after a year there he
managed to get political asylum in
France the French would not allow
Trotsky to live in Paris so he settled
in the coastal community of Rio he spent
almost two years there but then French
Soviet relations improved and the
government was pressured to deport him
for a year he stayed in Norway with
journalist Konrad Knudsen while there he
wrote the revolution betrayed which
further highlighted the failings of
Joseph Stalin a furious Stalin pressured
the Norwegian government and Trotsky was
once again deported he and his wife and
son they now headed for Trotsky's final
destination of New Mexico for just over
two years from January 1937 to April of
1939 they lived with artists Diego
Rivera and Frida Kahlo during that time
Trotsky had an affair with Frida even
though his wife and son were also living
under the same roof in April of 1939 the
Trotsky's moved into their own home a
few streets away from Diego and Frida it
was here that he wrote his strongest
attack on Stalin yet
article was titled Hitler and Stalin in
it he wrote about Stalin's hypocrisy and
signing a non-aggression pact with
Hitler it stated over the last three
years Stalin has labeled every one of
Lenin's comrades-in-arms
agents of Hitler having destroyed the
army party and decapitated the army
Stalin is now openly advancing his
candidature as Hitler's chief agents
[Music]
by now Trotsky was convinced that Stalin
would soon silence him on February 27th
1940 he wrote Trotsky's Testaments in
which he defended himself as a loyal
party member in the mid 1940s Trotsky's
house was swarmed by members of the
Russian secret police the NKVD Trotsky's
guards managed to fight them off by
following the failed assassination
attempt Trotsky wrote an article titled
Stalin seeks my death on June the 8th
1940 in which she stated that another
assassination attempt was absolutely
certain a month later on August the 20th
1940 a man walked into Trotsky study and
buried an icepick into his head
Trotsky did not die immediately though
rather he fought the attacker until his
bodyguards were able to come in and
subdue him Trotsky was rushed to the
local hospital according to James P
Kanin the secretary of the Socialist
Workers Party in the USA trotsky's last
words were I will not survive this
attack Stalin has finally accomplished
the task he attempted unsuccessfully
before he died the next day
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this several days a week so
hit that subscribe button to find out
about those if you're looking for
something else from me I've got another
channel called top tens you will find
that linked to below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]